Bonjour à toutes et à tous...
Ha, la vie de
lézard aux caraïbes...
la plage, le soleil...
et les ouragans !
A l'automne 2017
des chercheurs d'une collaboration
franco-américaine sont allés aux
caraïbes pour étudier la population
d'Anolis Scriptus, un petit lézard
que l'on trouve dans l'archipel turques
et Caïcos et dont l'activité
principale est de faire des pompes.
A l'origine les chercheurs étaient sur place
pour voir si la dératisation des
îles avait un effet sur la population de
ces petits lézards roi du fitness.
Mais l'histoire on a décidé autrement
Quatre jours après leur départ des îles
l'ouragan Irma a frappé l'archipel avec
des vents de 265 km heure suivi deux
semaines plus tard par l'ouragan Maria
avec des vents de plus de 200 kilomètres
heure.
Vous imaginez deux ouragans particulièrement violents
qui viennent ravager tout pile votre zone d'étude.
C'est la loose  !
Et bien non pas la loose
du tout au contraire : les scientifiques
ont réalisé qu'ils avaient là une
occasion inespérée de mesurer les
conséquences de l'ouragan sur
l'évolution d'une espèce isolée.
Il a déjà été montré que les épisodes
climatiques longs tels que les périodes
de sécheresse ou les périodes glaciaires
sont responsables d'une sélection
naturelle, mais qu'en est il des ouragans ?
C'est vrai qu'à priori un événement
aussi rapide et violent devrait
décimer la faune sans distinction.
Les chercheurs sont donc retourné sur
l'archipel quatre semaines plus tard et
ont trouvé une population d'Anolis Scriptus décimée
Ils ont alors mesuré les survivants
sous toutes les coutures et ont comparé
leurs résultats avec les mesures prises
avant les ouragans,
et les changements morphologiques sont flagrants :
Les survivants sont plus petits, ils ont des
coussinets adhésifs plus larges,  des
pattes avant plus longues,
mais aussi des pattes arrière plus courtes.
Ces lézards s'agrippent aux branches
grâce à de petites ridules sur leurs
coussinets.
Donc avoir de larges coussinets
apporte clairement un avantage pour
résister aux vents violents.
Mais comment expliquer la prédominance
des autres caractéristiques physiques
chez les survivants ?
C'est là que nos astucieux scientifiques
ont eu l'idée d'un dispositif de terrain
pour étudier le comportement des lézards
face à des vents violents.
Un anémomètre, une tige en bois pour
simuler une branche, le tout face à un
souffleur de feuilles mortes.
Les lézards sont soumis à des vents de
0 à 175 kilomètres/heure
Filmés avec une
caméra ultrarapide
on voit que le premier réflexe de nos
rois du fitness n'est pas de s'enfuir
mais de se placer face au vent derrière
la branche, et de se coller à celle ci.
Leurs pattes arrières lâchent en premier,
puis très vite les lézards sont emportés.
Des pattes avant plus longues permettent
de mieux agripper la branche
et des pattes arrière plus courtes réduisent la
prise au vent.
Les lézards présentant ces caractéristiques physiques
pourraient donc avoir eu un avantage évolutif.
Rassurez-vous le dispositif comprend
aussi un petit filet et de la mousse
pour réceptionner délicatement les
lézards.
Ils ont tous été relâchés dans
leur environnement naturel sains et saufs.
Cette étude donne ainsi un résultat
préliminaire, mais elle montre déjà que
les ouragans pourraient constituer une
pression de sélection et redéfinir
l'évolution des espèces sur leur passage.
Alors que les épisodes climatiques
extrêmes sont amenés à se multiplier,
ils pourraient avoir un rôle à jouer dans
les modèles actuels d'évolution des espèces.
Voilà donc ya pas de lézard cette
recherche est bien une petite tempête en
sciences de l'évolution !
N'hésitez pas à commenter et partager
cette vidéo je vous rappelle que vous
pourrez trouver toutes les sources dans
la description.
et abonnez vous !